RAJ AJRAWAT: Hi, everyone.
My name is Raj Ajrawat.
I'm a product specialist
here at Google Play.
Welcome to Playtime.
Thank you all for
being here today.
I'd like to actually introduce
both Mark and Jim before we
go ahead and get started.
So Mark, if you can go ahead
and introduce yourself,
and we'll go from there.
MARK PANELO: Hi, everyone.
I'm Mark Panelo.
I'm the senior director of
business development at Kabam,
and I lead platform partnership
strategy and operations.
JIM STERN: And I'm Jim
Stern, general manager
of the casual cards
division at Zynga,
working on global
games like Solitaire
and Gin Rummy Plus that have
a presence in the emerging
market, as well as some
games that are just
in the emerging markets.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Thank you
both for being here today.
We're really happy to
have you guys up here.
So in order to set up the
discussion, the panel,
for today, I wanted to just
talk about what we mean when
we talk about emerging markets.
Now, given the audience,
given the context,
when we say emerging
markets up here,
we're talking really any
non-Western, non-US market--
so essentially the
rest of the world.
There's a lot of economic
definitions for that.
And you might have users
in particular countries.
But really what we mean is any
user that's not US, UK, Canada.
The other thing
to call out, too,
is when we were actually
sitting here and talking
with our team about how we
want to structure the session,
we wanted to talk more
about how you can find
success in emerging markets.
I think it would be a little bit
disingenuous for us to come up
here and talk about how to
approach an emerging market
because many of you already
have users that are there,
and you're either deciding how
to react to them at this moment
or how to potentially drive
more business from them.
Now, given all of that, we
have three different things
that we're going to
be talking about,
three different topics that
we're going to focus on,
the first being pricing
and monetization.
So how do you price your goods
and services to these users?
What are some strategies or some
challenges that come with that?
The second one is around
localization, so not just
translating your
app or your game,
but being culturally relevant,
being culturally aware
of your users.
And then the third one is
the technical challenges.
What did you what do
you have to overcome
from a technical
perspective in order
to launch in a
particular market?
So starting off with pricing
and monetization, Mark,
I'd like to actually call
on you, in terms of the work
that you guys have done
in terms of pricing.
Give us a sense for
some of the challenges
you guys faced when it comes
to how you sell your goods,
how you sell your games
to users in those markets.
What were some ideas that you
guys started off with, and then
what were some solutions
that you went forward with?
MARK PANELO: Yeah, sure.
So at Kabam, we pride ourselves
on a really robust live ops
program and strategy.
And included in that is a
lot of different strategy
that we try to implement,
especially with pricing--
pricing sensitivity
analysis and testing.
For example, for
India and for Brazil,
not only do we have our standard
global pricing on our paywall,
but we actually put low
price entry points--
IEP entry points--
that's a little bit more
affordable for those markets.
We did see an uplift
in the purchase
velocity for those
lower-priced IEPs,
but we thought we could do more.
So we reached out to Google
Play to see whether or not
they could help us get more best
practice information for India
and Brazil.
So we met with Daniel
in the Brazil team,
and he actually mentioned
that our pricing
strategy in the Brazil
market is pretty appropriate.
Then we talked to [INAUDIBLE]
in the Google India team,
and she mentioned that
we're still a little bit too
expensive for that region.
So what we did is, instead of
putting a sub-$1.00 pricing--
USD pricing
equivalent-- in India,
we did something a
little bit lower.
We did a 10 rupee
offer, which equates
to around like $0.15 USD.
And while it was
priced really low,
we did make it up in volume, to.
So there is no one-size-fits-all
for emerging markets,
but we just got to test
different price points.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Yeah, for sure.
And Jim, with you guys
as well, with some
of the markets
you're approaching,
how did you think about that?
JIM STERN: Yeah, so let's
kind of take a look at it
from a different
perspective, which is just
taking a look at what the
cultural and worldwide events
are that are going on that
you have to be aware of.
So for example, with
our games in Turkey,
there is Ramadan and Eid,
which is very important.
And so we want to
make sure that--
we want to encourage the
gameplay during that time
period.
So we'll put special sales
on during that time period,
but won't run any
special UA campaigns
because we know we won't
that get that kind of return
during that time period.
And then other
things like VAT tax--
at the beginning of
the year, we started
charging VAT on top of all
of the packages that we had.
And we had to be really aware
of what the impact of that
was going to be on the players,
especially on the lower
end, the entry points.
Because on the
Google side at least,
there's no pricing
tiers so we can actually
set up whatever we need to.
And on the Apple
side, there are.
So we have to figure
out what kinds of items
we want to put in there
that will entice them more,
or how we even pop
up those messages
to get some of those
early players on board.
And then I'd say finally,
one other global perspective
is, do you even take a
look at the local currency.
So in the case of Turkey,
where we've got a big presence,
over this last year, there's
been a huge devaluation
in the market.
And what you need to
take a look at there,
then, is how do you
make sure that you're
being sensitive to
what's going on there.
Do you put on sales?
Do you actually reprice what
you're doing at that time?
Or do you try to come up
with alternative packages
like rewarded videos,
where they don't
have to spend as
much during the time
where the lira's a lot
lower, and really make sure
that they're able to
still continue to play.
RAJ AJRAWAT: So I want
to actually follow up
on that, too.
So this is interesting.
You're having to think about,
like, geopolitical issues that
are happening around the
world to understand, like,
currency devaluation.
What did you guys decide
to do in that moment?
Did you move with
rewarded video?
Did you change the pricing?
How did you actually
react to that?
JIM STERN: No, so
what we figured was
it was really
important to watch what
was going on in the market.
And because these are
lower price point entry,
it doesn't really impact that
part of the business as much.
So we decided to wait and
see what would happen.
And things actually
turned out fine in terms
of what players
were interested in
and being able to
engage in the game.
And it's the one piece that
I think is really important.
Don't react quickly,
and don't say,
OK, I'm going to reprice
everything right away.
Sit, wait, see what's going
to happen, and make sure
that you're really listening
to what the players want.
RAJ AJRAWAT: That's great.
And Mark, I wanted to
actually touch on something
you were talking
about previously.
We gave you guys advice
around what kind of pricing
makes sense in
particular markets.
Have you done any
testing beyond that,
in terms of maybe
even adjusting up
or below what we talked
about previously?
Or has there been any
sort of A/B testing
that you guys have
done with that?
MARK PANELO: I mean,
we A/B test everything.
But outside of
pricing, we actually
do-- because, like,
we create the Marvel
Contest of Champions game, we
know what characters resonate
in certain markets as well.
So we actually do when
we look at our offers
that we do in those
different markets,
we actually look
at which characters
and which packages makes
more sense for that reason.
So we do outside pricing.
We do tailor it culturally,
too, for the market.
RAJ AJRAWAT: So taking
that discussion now,
I'd actually like to transition
to this idea of localization.
So probably about six years
ago or five years ago,
I would have just told
you to translate your app,
and then call it a day.
That's completely
changed, right?
It's not just about translating
to Spanish, or Mandarin,
or Portuguese.
It's about running
sales during Eid,
or doing something specific
to those particular markets.
Jim, let's talk about some
of the work you guys did
with Okey in Turkey,
understanding sort
of how you guys first
approached that market,
thought about the way you wanted
to set up the game, and then
some of the things that you did
in terms of actually delivering
content to users there.
It'd be great to just
walk through all of that.
JIM STERN: OK.
Yeah, Okey as a tile-based gin
game, similar to Rummicube.
And it's very popular.
It's very traditional in
their card houses there.
So people have been
playing it for years.
And they play socially,
they play for money.
There's a lot that goes on
around that as a community.
So we figured, let's tap
into something that actually
resonates with that community.
There are 80 million
or so people in Turkey,
and there's a large portion that
actually play the game as well.
So our first
important thing to do
is make sure that we had
synchronous gameplay, just
set it up that way.
How do you make
it so that people
can get on-- two players,
three players, four players.
On top of that, we then added
community and customer service.
And with the customer service,
it was important to have people
who were from Turkey, not only
how to speak the language--
like I said, you don't
worry about, necessarily,
just the translation--
but really understood
the mentality
of people who play the game
and what they're looking for.
And then we finally added
a component on top of that,
where they can wager
for chips and really
get that additional
excitement around it.
And what was important, I think,
throughout this whole thing
was the timing, the
pacing of the game,
what the tiles look like,
even your avatar and canned
phrases that weren't just
translated through some app,
but things that
were typically known
within that particular culture.
RAJ AJRAWAT: There was one
partner we were talking to
before the panel.
And she was mentioning how
they leverage their community
inside the app.
So they have a very strong,
passionate user base
that actually just
volunteer their time.
They were given a space in terms
of becoming a brand ambassador,
an app ambassador, for them.
And they actually reach
out to these users
in particular markets
as the individual
that represents that country.
It makes the user feel
extremely happy to have
that honor, especially
if they love the service
or they love the app.
But they essentially
become a sounding board
for any changes that can
happen in that local market.
So much like what we did with
Daniel and [INAUDIBLE] in India
and in Brazil, they sort
of act as the individual
that you can reach
out to and say, hey,
we're trying to get
this message across.
Does this make sense?
Is this the right messaging
that we want to say?
And many times, they'll
actually come back
and say, no, you mean
to say this instead.
So it's a good check
on a lot of the work
that they're doing in terms
of approaching those markets.
And it's ideally
somewhat lightweight
in terms of leveraging
those resources,
leveraging your users to
actually get that information.
But Mark, how have
you guys thought
about culturalization,
localization
for your offerings?
MARK PANELO: So something
interesting that we do--
we, Kabam, actually have really
deep roots with UC Berkeley.
And what we've been doing--
like all of our founders
came from Cal.
And what we did with them is
we partnered with the Haas
Business School to do
a research competition
to see which markets
outside of the tier 1's
have the highest
growth potential.
And there's a bigger
opportunity there.
So it's no surprise that both
India and Brazil, as well as
Southeast Asia came
up in the research.
So right now, we're
actually moving to phase 2.
And in phase 2,
actually, we're going
to be partnering with
an university in India
to go a little bit more deeper
on, not only just the game
market over there, but also
the game tech and the player
profile.
And the reason why
we're doing that
with the university in India
is because we identify them
as a growth market and
an emerging market,
those people who are
on the ground there.
So that's why we
wanted to do that.
So that's how we're
kind of learning
from the folks over
there on, the ground.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Interesting.
I don't know if
you can say this.
Is this like a
financial relationship,
or is it just purely research,
or how is that structured?
MARK PANELO: Pure research.
I mean, we're partnering
with universities.
There's a prize
for whoever wins.
So it just helps
for their tuition.
RAJ AJRAWAT: OK, that's great.
Yeah, so I mean, I
think that there's
a lot of these different things
to think about when you're
obviously trying to sell
your specific service
to these markets.
I'd like to potentially
now transition
to some of these
technical issues
that a lot of our partners face.
And actually, we were
talking previously,
the panel, that even
size can be a big issue.
So Jim, walk us through
some of the technical things
that you had to think
about before you approached
the market, or also
just technical issues
that you might have
encountered after you entered.
JIM STERN: That we were
surprised about later.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Right, that
you were surprised about it.
How did you react to them?
How did you guys
build in flex to be
able to address those issues
for your users as well?
JIM STERN: So we had a couple
of different things going
on with a few of our games.
So in the case of Okey
that I was talking about,
it's predominantly
played in Turkey.
And the closest AWS server that
we could get was in Germany.
So there was some
latency issues--
not horrible.
But we were able to
find servers that
were local within Turkey
that were price-competitive
as well, that actually
were much better in terms
of the latency issue.
So we were able to hook
them up over there.
We've also had situations
like with Poker
where we thought, OK,
this is a global game how
do we target the particular
emerging markets?
Let's segment the
servers based off
of the different languages
of the different countries
where the people are playing.
And we found that actually
had an issue on liquidity,
that people weren't able to
find other players because they
were on different servers.
So to accommodate for
that, we put everybody back
into a single set
of servers again.
And in order to customize
the game for them,
we tried to give them
customized events
that we would customize for
that particular culture,
but then make
something else that
was a little bit more generic
for the rest of the world.
And then in the case of Rangoli
Rekha, which is a match 3
game that we did in India,
it was very important
that we knew the customer base.
So it's predominantly Android.
So we focused on Android.
They don't have the
same access to Wi-Fi,
so we had to make sure that
the file size was down,
so we kept it 20 megs.
And based on the research
that we had done,
we found that up to
40% of the people
find other fileshare servers
to go to download the game.
So we made sure it was
accessible through services
like FireShare in
order for them to be
able to download their games.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Now,
Mark, did you guys
have any similar issues around
size or anything like that?
Or is that a consideration
for you guys?
JIM STERN: It's definitely
a huge consideration.
So four years ago, when Marvin
Contest of Champions launched,
players actually had
to be on Wi-Fi in order
to download the game.
The game is huge.
I would probably say, on device,
it's around like 700 megabytes.
So you can see that could
be a hurdle for acquisition.
So shortly after that, we had to
quickly pivot our central tech
strategy.
So what we did is we
made our initial download
sub-100 megabytes.
And what that did for
us is it enabled players
to download the
game over cellular.
And while they're playing
through the tutorial,
our game leverages
on-demand resources
to download the
rest of the package.
So not only did we
see optimization
in our yields and
our CPIs, but also it
made our game more accessible
in the emerging markets where
the infrastructure wasn't
really fully developed
and Wi-Fi wasn't
readily available.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Yeah,
and I mean, I think
that highlights a lot of what
we were talking about earlier
today, when you saw Dom up here
on stage, why we're so focused
on size reduction.
You can see the
benefits around actually
taking this type of model--
a more modular approach, more
dynamically loading content.
And that's really why
we built the bundle.
That's why we built
that technology.
And I can't reiterate
that enough.
I think we've seen a
lot of partners report
to us how important that's
been for their business.
I mean, just something so simple
as size reduction can really
drive that.
Now, were there any
technical challenges
that you had to overcome
through that size reduction,
or through that kind of like
dynamically-loading information
that maybe you could
share some details on?
MARK PANELO: In terms
of the actual tech?
Gosh, I'm not an engineer.
I really can't tell
you all the details.
But it was definitely
not an easy process.
I think the time
that we said we need
to do this versus
when we actually
executed was a good six months.
So I would say if you
guys are starting off
from a full-package download to
actually changing your strategy
and doing an initial
download, take some time
to think through it.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Yeah.
And so that's a good
thing to call out, too.
I think when we have
these conversations
with our partners,
a lot of times
it's not just a quick change
that you can put into place.
This is really an architecture
decision at the end of the day.
And you kind of have
to leverage a lot
of resources to
make that happen.
So that kind of definitely
lines up with a lot of things
that we're talking
to partners about.
But I'd like to maybe just take
stock of a lot of these ideas.
And if you could maybe talk
about one or two things
that you'd want the
audience to take away from,
something that we can hopefully
take away as an actionable item
that they can test back home
with some of their colleagues.
Jim, maybe we'll start with you.
What are a few things that
you can talk about that
if you're trying to prioritize
these items and these tasks?
What are things they
can do to try and find
success in these markets?
JIM STERN: I'd say,
first and foremost,
if you're looking to do
a game or an application
in a particular market,
make sure you've really
done your research to know
what are the traditions there,
what do people glom
onto, why do they do it.
The more you can actually have
it built there as well, where
the people know the traditions,
they know the culture,
it's much better.
Because even the subtleties
that they put into the game
make an incredible difference.
Same-- like I was talking about
before-- customer service,
have it there.
They'll understand how
to talk with the people
there, how to
communicate with them.
And I wouldn't just
segment it, I guess,
to creating an app for
a particular market.
But if you have
a larger app that
is global, how do you tap
into those emerging markets?
And in some cases, it is
customizing events, or sales,
or whatever it is that you
want to put out to them.
It will cost a little bit more.
It will take more
time to put together.
But they value that,
and they really
enjoy seeing that they're
an important piece to what's
going on.
You can also get into
those emerging markets
if you're worldwide.
Because like I was talking
about with liquidity,
there maybe these
smaller countries
where you don't have--
it's not profitable enough for
you to build something just
for that, but you
can tap into it
by leveraging all the
rest of the other people.
So don't just ignore
emerging markets
because you don't think
you can get into it.
Leverage everything
else that you're
doing in terms of the
rest of the world.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Yeah,
and Mark, I think
if you could give us maybe a few
things to think about as well.
MARK PANELO: Yeah, I mean, like
from a pricing perspective,
I would just say
A/B test everything.
I mean, sometimes the biggest
wins and learnings come out
of trial and error.
But I guess my more
general takeaway and advice
I could give is to don't
be afraid to ask for help,
and leverage your
external resources,
whether it's Google Play,
or local universities,
or even your peers
in the industry.
Chances are you'll
learn something
about emerging markets
that you didn't know.
And the advice is free, too.
RAJ AJRAWAT: Yep, definitely.
[CHUCKLING]
Awesome.
Well, thank you both for
being up here today--
super helpful, and we
really appreciate you guys
sharing this detail.
And actually, one more thing
I wanted to call out, too.
So there is a new
feature that we
had talked about
earlier that's launching
on the Play Console, which
is called country targeting.
So for those of you who've used
locale targeting previously,
you might have had
some issues where
users, for example
in India, they
set their phones to English US.
And so you're not necessarily
able to actually deliver
content that's specific
to a particular market.
But we currently have that
in an early access program.
And so I'd love for
everyone to take a look.
If you go to
g.co/play/countrytargeting.
Again, that URL is
Thank you both.
MARK PANELO: Thanks
for having us.
JIM STERN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]